- mating e to the 1.45 using a Taylor
polynomial about x equals two what is
the least degree of the polynomial that
assures an error smaller than 0.001
in general if you see a situation like
this where we're talking about
approximating a function with the Taylor
polynomial centered about some value and
we want to know well how many terms do
we need what degree do we need to bound
the error that's a pretty good clue that
we're going to be using the LeGrande or
taylor's remainder theorem and just as a
reminder of that this is a review of
Taylor's remainder theorem and it tells
us that the absolute value of the
remainder for the nth degree Taylor
polynomial it's going to be less than
this business right over here now n is
the degree of our polynomial that we're
in question so that's the N the X is the
x value at which we are calculating that
error in this case it's going to be this
one point four five and C is where our
Taylor polynomial is centered but what
about our M well our M is an upper bound
on the absolute value of the n plus one
derivative of our function and that
might seem like a mouthful but when we
actually work through the details of
this example it'll make it a little bit
more concrete so for this particular
thing we're trying to estimate we're
trying to estimate eetu the X so I could
write f of X let me write this this way
so f of X is equal to e to the X and
we're trying to estimate F of one point
four five and let's just to get get the
bound here to figure out what M is let's
just remind ourselves that well the
first derivative of this is going to be
e to the X the second derivatives going
to be e to the X I'll go at the nth
derivative is going to be e to the X the
n plus one third derivative is going to
be e to the X so the n plus 1 the
derivative of F is going to be is going
to be e to the X which is convenient
these types of problems are very very
hard if it's difficult to bound the n
plus 1 derivative well this we know we
know that e to the X we know that e to
the X and I could even say the absolute
value of this but this is going to be
positive is going to be less than or
equal to let's say this is going to be
less than or equal to e square
cared-for zero is less than X is less
than or equal to 2 e to the X isn't
bounded over the entire 4 4 over its
entire domain if X goes to infinity e to
the X will also go to infinity but here
I set up an interval I've set up an
interval that contains the X we care
about remember the X we care about is
one point four five and it also contains
where our function is centered our
function is centered at two so we know
we're bounded by e squared so we can say
we can use e squared as our M we can use
e squared as our M we were able to
establish this bound and so doing that
we can now go straight to la garage our
bound we can say we can say that the
remainder of our nth degree Taylor
polynomial we want to solve for n we
want to figure out what n gives us the
appropriate bound evaluated at one point
four five when X is one point four five
is going to be less than or equal to the
absolute value our M is e squared e
squared over over n plus 1 factorial
times one point four five that's our X
that we care about that's where we're
calculating the error we're trying to
bound the error - where we're centered -
two to the n plus 1 power now one point
four five minus two that is negative
zero point five five so let me just
write that so this is this is negative
zero point five five to the n plus one
power and we want to figure out for what
n is all of this business is all of this
business going to be less than 0.001
let's do a little bit of algebraic
manipulation here this term is positive
this is going to be positive this right
over here or this part of it's good not
it's not an independent term but this
the EDA square is going to be positive n
plus 1 factorial going to be positive
the negative zero point five five to
some power that's going to flip between
being positive or negative but since
we're taking the absolute value we could
write it this way we could write
e squared e squared since we're taking
the absolute value times 0.55 to the n
plus 1 over n plus 1 factorial has to be
less than has to be less than 0.001 or
since we want to solve for one less
since we want to solve for n let's
divide both sides by e squared so we
could write we could write let's find
the N where 0.55 to the n plus 1 power
over n plus 1 factorial is less than is
less than 0.001 over over e squared now
to play with this we're going to have to
use a calculator it exists we're going
from this point we're just going to try
larger and larger ends until we get an N
that makes this true and we find when we
want to find the smallest possible n
that makes this true but let's get out
our calculator so that we can actually
so that we can actually do this so first
I'm just going to figure out what is one
thousandth divided by E squared so make
sure it's cleared out so let's take a
squared I'm going to take its reciprocal
and I'm going to multiply that times a
thousandth so times point zero zero 1 is
equal to so it's it's about so I'll say
so it's three zeros this is a ten
thousandth and then three five so it's
three zeros so I'll say one three six so
this needs to be this needs to be less
than zero point one two three and I'll
say one three six if I can find an N
that is less than this then I am in that
I am in good shape actually let me say
this less than one three five I want to
be less than that value then I can be
then I will be in good shape this is a
little bit more than one three five but
if I can find an N where that is less
than this that I'm in good shape let me
write this zero point five five to the n
plus 1 over n plus one factorial
so let's try out some ends and I'm gonna
have to get my calculator out so let's
see it did I do that right yeah 0 0 0 1
3 5 if we get something below this then
we're in good shape because this is even
less than that all right so let's do it
let's see what this is equal to when I
don't know when n is equal to 2 I could
start at N equals 1 N equals 2 N equals
3 but at the more and then further if N
equals 2 is good enough that I might try
N equals 1 but if N equals 2 isn't good
enough that I'm going to go to N equals
3 or N equals 4 so let's start with
actually let's just start with N equals
3 so if N equals 3 it's going to be 0.5
5 to the fourth power divided by 4
factorial so let's see is that let's do
that
so 0.55 to the fourth power is equal to
that divided by 4 factorial so divided
by 4 factorial is 24 so that's nowhere
near low enough so let's try N equals 4
if N equals 4 then it's going to be this
to the fifth power divided by 5
factorial so 0.55 to the fifth power is
equal to and then divided by 5 factorial
is 5 factorial is 120 divided by 120 is
equal to that we're almost there with N
equals 4 I'm guessing that N equals 5
will do the trick so for N equals 5 so
let's clear this out so for N equals 5
we're going to raise to the 6th power
and divided by 6 factorial and so let's
just remind ourselves what six factorial
is 720 I could have actually done that
in my head but anyway alright so let's
see we're going to go 0.55 to that
remember our n is 5 so we're going to
raise to the sixth power to the sixth
power and then we're going to divide by
720 divided by 720 is equal to and this
number for sure is less than this number
right over here we got four zeroes
before this 3 after the decimal
you have three so when N equals five
it got is sufficiently low enough this
remainder is going to be sufficiently
low it's going to be less than this
value right over here so what is the
least degree of the polynomial that is
that assures an error smaller than 1000
and the answer is five our n if n is
five we're definitely going to be under
this